the federal indictments against Donald
Trump have just been issued he is being
charged over false claims about the 2020
election particularly his effort to
overturn the results and the lead up to
the obstruction of official proceedings
we'll go through the I believe there's
four counts here but this is it they're
saying that Donald Trump was engaged in
any conspiracy essentially against the
United States we're also hearing there
will be likely another indictment coming
out of Georgia with potentially more
than a dozen defendants there are also
several unindicted co-conspirators in
this charge ladies and gentlemen this is
probably the most serious effort taken
by Biden's doj explicitly to interfere
in the 2024 election to prevent Trump
from winning we've heard a lot of people
say that Trump can't win they talk about
polls but the polls are actually showing
Donald Trump is doing better than ever
and that he's either tied with or
beating Joe Biden so what is Joe Biden
doing exactly this